واسرع
لاوروبا ستدفعنا 100 مليار دولار ثمن
خسارتنا في اوكرانيا وكيف تعلن الانضمام
لحلف النيتو
[موسيقى]
خط احمر ولن نتجاوزه وبينما تهاجم
الطائرات الاوكرانيه في اجواء موسكو من
جديد اوكرانيا تعلن عن الفاعل والامم
المتحده تتنصل والكريم لم يتوعد وبولندا
تشكل كتائبها لمواجهات باجنر وبوتين يفاجئ
افريقيا بهديه ثمينه واسبانيا تدخل خط
الممولين للحرب الاوكرانيه بدبابات
المانيه وايران تقبض على خليه حاول
التفجير اكثر من اربعين قنبله فما هو
الهدف وللمره الثانيه
على حدودها فمتى سينتهي رصيدكم من الصبر
يمضي في قراره والاسرائيليون ينتفضون
واليمنيون يعلن غضبهم امام السويد
والدنمارك روسيا ترفع الكارت الاحمر
حرب المسيرات ولا غيرها هي ما يسود
الاجواء الاوكرانيه لتتوسع هذه الحرب
قليلا وتصل الى اجواء موسكو فيالها من
معارك شعواء وبعد ان كانت قد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجوم اوكراني
بطائرتين مسيرتين على اهداف في موسكو وذلك
باسقاطها عبر منظومات الحرب الالكترونيه
دون وقوع اصابات لتفضحك يا بهويه من قام
بهذا الهجوم فحسب ما افادت صحيفه رفض
الاوكرانيه لان الهجوم الليليه بطائرات
مسيره على موسكو كان عمليه خاصه لقسم
المخابرات الرئيسيه بوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وكانهم يقولون للكرملين قسم
المخابرات هو عدوكم وانتم وضميركم كما
يقول العرب في مقاله وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه كان تحتفظ بحقها في اتخاذ اجراءات
قاسيه ردا على الهجمات بالطائرات المسيره
التي ينفذها نظامك واما لاعب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي حتى وزاره الدفاع على ضرب
اهداف غير متوقعه في اوكرانيا ولا تقتصر
فقط على مواقع التخزين ومراكز الطاقه
ومحطات الوقود بما يحدث تداعيات وتاثيرا
كبيرا للغايه عليهم وذلك ردا على استهداف
قوات كييف المواقع المدنيه في روسيا فيما
تتنصل الامم المتحده عن الاوكرانيين في
هذا الهجوم وتدعو الطرفي الصراع الى تجنب
اي ردود فعل من شانها تصعد الاوضاع اكثر
وذلك بحسب تصريح نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده فرحان حقا لتواصل
اسراب المسيرات الاوكرانيه تنفيذ هجماتها
وهنا قاده الدفاع الروسيه انه تم احباط
محاوله من قبل نظام لتنفيذ هجوم ارهابي
باستخدام سبعه عشره مسيره على اهداف في
اراضي شبه جزيره القرن ناقده انه تم اسقاط
اربع عشره مسيره بواسطه وسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه منها 11 مسيرات تحطمت في
البحر الاسود وسقطت ثلاث اخرى في اراضي
شبه الجزيره وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه لا
تتركوا لهجمات اوكرانيا اي مجال عن اي
قدرات نتحدث لكن مهلا مهلا اتعلمون كيف
يسقط الروس المسيرات الكترونيا يتم ذلك عن
طريق جيش من الهاكرز او ما يسمى بجيش
الدفاع السيبراني اها لا يزال الجزائر
حمزه بن دلاج في السجون الامريكيه والذي
يعتبر من اخطر الهاكرز في العالم فمتى
ستستعده الجزائر دعونا نكمل مسارنا السابق
ومن معارك الجو الى الحرب في احشاء البحار
والمحيطات حيث اعلنت هيئه الامن الف
[موسيقى]
يفصلها عن روسيا واوكرانيا وهناك اكدت
ترامب انه بمجرد عودته الى البيت الابيض
سيجبر اوروبا على الدفع ما دفعته امريكا
لاوكرانيا اذا لم يكن اكثر من ذلك وقال
وساخبر اوروبا لديكم نقص في التمويل يبلغ
100 مليار دولار حسنا ادفعها هل وجد الرجل
الاصفر بقرته الحلوب الجديده دعونا ننتظر
كيف سيستعيد ترامب اموال بلاده وفي سياق
اجراءات الولايات المتحده قالت مجله يزويك
انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو خط احمر بالنسبه
لواشنطن لان هذا الامر سيزيد من احتمال
وقوع صدام مباشر مع روسيا لكن وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
ويعبر عن رغبتي في انضمام بلاده للنيتو
حيث قال انك يفقد تنال عضويه في الحلف في
القمه المقبله في واشنطن
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن اجواء المعارك وبعد ان كانت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت عن اغتنامها
سبع دبابات على محور الزبرجيا
لترسل السلطات الاسبانيه شحنه جديده من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا حيث
[موسيقى]
المدرعات كجزء من المساعده العسكريه فهل
تصبح غنيمه جديده
الاحداث والتطورات اعلنت وزاره الامن
الايراني عن القاء القبض على عناصر تابعين
لخليه كانت تنوي تفجير قبر قائد فيلق
القدس السابق قاسم سليماني مضيفه انها
عثرت معهم على ثلاث واربعين قنبله كانوا
ينمون استخدامها للتفجير اعلنت وكاله
السوشيال عن وصول الغواصه الامريكيه
الى كوريا الجنوبيه في ثاني عمليه نشر
لقطع بحريه الامريكيه رئيسيه في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه هذا الشهر ووصفت هذه
الخطوه بانها رساله تحد من واشنطن
بينما كان كم قد رد على عمليه نشر القطاع
الامريكيه الاولى بالصواريخ الباليستيه هل
يضرب جارته بالصواريخ النوويه هذه المره
بعد ان صوت الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بالقراءه
الثالثه على قانون التعديلات القضائيه
لتتواصل الاحتجاجات الكثيفه والمناهضه
لمشروع قانون التعديلات القضائيه وتندلع
اشتباكات بين الشرطه والمحتجين امام مقر
الكنيست حيث يتظاهر الالاف فالحان وقت
اسقاط حكومه نتنياهو 100 الاف اليمنيين في
مظاهرات حاشده في العاصمه صنعاء ومدن اخرى
احتجاجا على تدنيس القران وحرقه في
الدنمارك والسويد وطالبت الاحتجاجات الدول
الاسلاميه بعقد قمه طارئه والاتفاق على
اجراءات جماعيه ضد الحكومات التي تدمس
القران
[موسيقى]